we begin the day with a warning to
civilians in russian occupied eastern
ukraine get out while you can bombs and
bloodshed are on the way
ukraine's military is preparing an
attack to win back territory that is
still occupied by russia the messaging
for civilians is frightening and it's
meant to be that way but military
analysts say the warnings could be an
over abundance of caution mixed with
some wishful thinking ukrainian forces
are not able to launch a major attack
because they are still waiting for
weapons delivery will take weeks we're
told in the meantime russian troops are
expected to inch their way forward with
no let up in the fight
consider the words of the governor from
the eastern region of luhansk
everything that can burn is on fire
around 95 percent of that region is now
under russian control
several donesk is a focus of the attacks
amid fierce fighting ukrainian forces
say they have held a chemical plant in
the city where about 500 civilians are
thought to be sheltered the luhansk
governor has also warned that russia is
preparing an even bigger offensive in
the region
western countries have been delivering
increasingly heavy weapons to ukraine to
help it fight back against russian
aggression and those deliveries include
heavy field artillery multiple rocket
launcher systems have also been promised
among other equipment that germany is
providing seven high-tech mobile
artillery units to ukraine the ukrainian
defense ministry says those have now
arrived and formed part of the country's
arsenal
it's no surprise
no news germany has faced criticism for
perceived foot dragging over sending
weapons to ukraine german chancellor
olaf schultz again today underlined
berlin's commitment to supporting
ukraine
and russia's relentless war of
aggression against ukraine is a
fundamental blow to peace in europe and
a blatant breach of international law
this international
it represents an apocal upheaval in
europe and the world
a turning point for all of us
ukraine belongs among us it belongs to
the european family
a milestone on this preconditional
european path is the status of an
accession candidate
the eu member states will be discussing
this in the next few days
germany is in favor of a positive
decision in favor of ukraine and i will
push for a unified position at the
european council
and it's quite clear that we will
continue to support ukraine
we will continue to support ukraine with
weapons for as long as ukraine needs our
support
well my first guest tonight knows both
worlds of ukrainian diplomacy and
ukrainian big business
alexander
is a former ambassador to austria from
ukraine and is currently chief advisor
to the ceo of naftogas that's ukraine's
state energy company he's also the
author of ukraine versus darkness that's
a collection of essays based on the two
and a half decades that he spent as a
career diplomat and speech writer for
ukrainian leaders
mr shepard it's good to have you on the
program tonight
let me ask you
this question on gas if ukraine wants to
prevent
russia from earning
money
on gas exports
why isn't
ukraine preventing
russian gas from transiting across
ukrainian territory or is that the case
thank you for having me
well the answer is very simple because
we know that countries like germany
austria still need the gas the company's
policy and the company's position
and the position of many many our
co-workers quite frankly is clear uh
russian gas should
there should be a gas embargo in russia
and oil embargo in russia but we don't
want to be the ones who
just cut through
i
we need we need to germany austria and
other countries uh to do it on
themselves on their own and i think they
are approaching that uh right decision
introducing gas embargo and then of
course ukraine will play along
and let me ask you too mr shepherd just
to clarify for our viewers
is ukraine still
receiving transit fees from russia when
that gas or oil crosses its territory
i mean are you making money
surreal as it sounds yes it's correct we
are fulfilling our
contractual obligations
uh as a
gas transit country between russia and
european union we are not uh taking and
buying uh russian gas since
uh
2015 i think but we are transiting the
russian gas that's correct
we know that ukraine is paying
a huge price
for its its sovereignty and it's it's
freedom right now casualties in defining
are are huge
is the military aid is it getting
through so i mean sufficiently i mean
are you convinced that western countries
are committed to helping ukraine win
this war
believe uh in our partners in the west
uh we are confident that they understand
the nature of this war
that we are fighting for our freedom and
we have no other way but to keep
fighting because we know
what will happen once we stop there will
be no ukraine there will be no ukrainian
language there will be no our freedom
there was actually a rather remarkable
article published in moscow
at the early stage of this war it was
titled what we should do with ukraine
and it said very clearly um that it
should be a genocide of ukrainians
it spoke about
ukraine's collective guilt and
collective punishment that it deserves
for at least one generation so we have
no other way but to fight what i like
our foreign minister said
even if we don't get the weapons we'll
fight with spades
well a an article in the new york times
today um reports that u.s officials
um are briefing that the weapons ukraine
has received or is receiving
will help it to hold on
to its territory
do you agree with that i mean is that
enough for your country
um in terms of of ending this conflict
satisfactorily
well uh the uh land lease program on the
part of the united states uh is
open-ended uh so uh there is no clear
limit to what ukraine uh needs uh to
receive and will receive i hope we
indeed will receive whatever it takes
uh we know that uh what was already
agreed upon
is a lot and it can make huge difference
on the front line the problem is it
hasn't for the most part
hasn't come yet from the united states
and uh from uh many european countries
including unfortunately germany uh
although today it was a huge news that
finally uh german howitzers arrived in
germany and for that we thank from the
whole heart
i want to ask you about
perceptions of of russia
french president emmanuel macron
he has been reminding people
particularly last week that ukraine
will have to negotiate with russia
in the end
is there a rift between the ukrainian
perceptions of russia and how western
countries such as france
see russia
well i think everybody is changing their
perception of russia
after this war everybody who had
any kind of trust into russia's
rationality or
civility
uh has to rethink and reconsider uh
the ways he saw russia he or she saw
russia
in the last couple of decades
so
uh
on ukraine's part i can say as someone
who never was enemy of russia uh
russia is dead for me like for many many
ukrainians um
it's it will never forget whatever good
uh was connecting our two countries and
two nations it has been destroyed in
this three months of this barbaric
almost four months with this barbaric uh
war
uh but yeah uh macron is right in the
way that
at a certain point uh we will have to
negotiate only uh will negotiate when
putin is forced to negotiate uh and he
will be forced to negotiate to negotiate
only when he feels
that he's losing the war
and that might take a while i'm afraid
what's your take on what we continue to
hear from some german lawmakers and
policymakers
that
europe germany should not push vladimir
putin
too far because we still want to be able
to negotiate with him when this war is
is over um are they guilty of giving uh
an aggressive
russia
a future free pass
absolutely they are guilty they are
guilty
of uh allowing putin to grow and to
become this monster they are guilty of
um
not listening to what ukraine was saying
for years about putin's plans they are
guilty of
selling the soul of europe to this
monster in moscow and embracing him
while he was planning this war and if
they are saying right now that uh we
should
be careful about the emotions of this
insane uh cynical evil person in moscow
then once again they are guilty they are
guilty of being either foolish or greedy
or uh
not courageous enough
and despite all of that mr chairman um
the european union is expected this week
to grant ukraine
candidacy status
to one day become a member of the eu i
mean given that this process is likely
to take years
sometimes it can take decades
um why is this official recognition
why is it so important for your country
because this war is about
freedom
uh freedom uh
to be
what we want to be and we want to be
with europe we want to be like europe we
want to be a success uh like europe uh
and just to be recognized
just to have this our wish officially
recognized by the european union knowing
how distant europe was from that point
just four months ago
just it means a lot it's it's the right
symbolism at the right moment to the
right country to the right nation
i know that you have worked with
ukrainian leaders since independence 31
years ago
how would you describe
president vladimir zielinski's
leadership
at
the current time i mean he is a wartime
president well we are immensely proud of
him like uh like uh uh
ukrainian american journalist uh
vladislav davidson said
zelensky is a hero who knew uh and uh he
said the joke he tweeted it jokingly but
indeed president zelensky is a hero for
many many people uh for many ukrainians
like myself we'll never forget uh the
day of february 24th when we went
to bed
hearing these planes russian planes uh
flying over kiev and not knowing uh uh
to which kind of reality we'll wake up
tomorrow and then waking up next day
and seeing president zielinski uh
sending this message hello ukrainians
i'm here i stayed i don't need
right i need uh ammo and that was the
moment when we started really really
believing in victory
alessandra we've covered a lot of
territory
tonight but there's still much more to
talk about we hope that you can join us
again here on the day thank you
thank you
and for more now i want to go to our
colleague emanuel she is in kiev tonight
emmanuel let's talk about these
important heavy weapons that ukrainian
forces are waiting for today was an
important delivery day wasn't it
exactly in fact germany had promised it
would deliver heavy weapons and it had
been a bone of contention between kiev
and berlin after weeks and months passed
and there was no
no sight no sign of those howitzers in
particular here in ukraine so the fact
that they arrived today along with
trained uh ukrainian
soldiers who are trained in germany well
this is a boost for the morale of the
ukrainian armed forces you know they've
been saying time and again they need
heavy weapons of course those german
howitzers won't do all the job but it's
better than nothing it's better than no
heavy weapons at all and it certainly
reinforces uh the trust between the two
countries so definitely a moral boost
and hopefully uh you know uh there will
be a put
on the front line where it's entirely
darkly needed on this eastern front line
where the last few days have seen an
increasing uh an increased fighting
yeah you might want to talk to me about
the situation on the front lines in
eastern ukraine what do we know
well it appears that uh russia through
its reserves in a lot in in its latest
uh
be to try and conquer all of luhansk it
almost uh
dominates everything there if you talk
if we talk about uh the city of severo
doniask for example it's almost
completely russian
occupied by russian right now there's
only by russian troops right now there's
only this chemical plant we were
mentioning earlier in the report where
hundreds of civilians are trapped and
there's no way into severe done there's
no way out either because the bridges
are leading to the city and the highway
leading to the city have been destroyed
by heavy shelling and on both sides both
the russian side and the ukrainian side
the forces the armed forces are
suffering heavy heavy losses so a
situation that has dramatically
escalated and ukrainian armed forces
warn
that the next couple of days will show
decide decisive battles for the
domination of donbass
and what about the situation for the
suburbs
around kiev where you are i know that
you've been visiting kiev's suburbs they
were damaged extensively at the
beginning of this war
what have you been seeing
well brent it's been heartbreaking to
see european to see hostile where also
possible
war crimes were committed those are the
places where regularly the forensic
teams the ukrainian forensic teams are
uncovering uh mass graves and uh proofs
through testimonies of what has happened
when russian troops went through they
retreated
two months ago already but when you
drive through when you walk through
those towns you see the pictures of
desolation you see destroyed
buildings everywhere so this will take
years to rebuild even
knowing how resilient the ukrainian
people are this is just scenes of
desolation
with and no end inside knowing that most
of the eastern part and a southern part
of the country are still subjected to
indiscriminate shelling on residential
areas in particular
our correspondent emmanuel chans
reporting tonight from kiev
thank you
and for more now i'm joined by chris
dougherty he's a weapons and defense
specialist at the center for a new
american security in washington d.c
chris it's good to have you on the
program
let me get your take on
the the battle against time here i mean
we've we're hearing from the ukrainian
military that their soldiers still have
to wait several weeks until they have
the weapons that they need to launch a
counter-offensive against the russians
does that mean that the russians for the
time being have the upper hand
i think so as far as the battle for um
places like sever donetsk and
lysischonsk um go in that portion of the
dunbas there's such a significant
concentration of russian artillery that
no matter what the ukrainians do they're
going to be facing overwhelming fires
we've seen numerous reports of what that
does to the combat forces in those areas
and how difficult it is for them to hold
on to that terrain
we're four months into this
war and today we saw the first delivery
of german heavy weaponry in ukraine
how significant is is today
in and of itself not terribly
significant but as part of a larger
pattern of western aid to the ukrainians
i think it is quite significant
i think what we're going to see
increasingly is ever more capable
ukrainian forces operating western
rather than former soviet equipment with
higher
capabilities with more effective
targeting with longer ranges with better
communications capabilities and in
theory that should allow the ukrainians
to offset russian advantages in total
manpower the number of armored fighting
vehicles and the number of artillery
tubes
is that going to allow
ukrainian forces to push
russian forces back or are we talking
about
um static
front lines here for the foreseeable
future
i think you're going to see static front
lines for the foreseeable future but i
think the ukrainians will be able to
strike
in depth behind the russian front lines
in a way that they may not be able to
right now so rather than continually
seeding ground to a slow grinding
russian offensive like we've seen in
several next you're going to see a more
an even more static line where the
ukrainians are holding their ground
potentially even counter-attacking in
some limited places but they simply
right now and in for the foreseeable
future don't have the mass of fighters
and equipment necessary to create a
breakthrough and then exploit it
so are we headed though eventually to a
place where there will be a clear
winner here a victor
will ukraine be able to claim victory or
are we looking here at a protracted war
of attrition
i think we're looking at a protected war
of attrition i wish i could say
otherwise but
the facts as they stand on the ground
the quantity of forces arrayed and the
static nature of the lines at this
moment suggests to me that we're in for
much more fighting like this and i think
the question going forward is less the
exact number of fighters at the front or
the number of weapons being delivered on
either side but what are the long-term
implications of political will and
economic steadfastness of the two sides
yeah i think the
calendar is going to be long and heavy
and i'm sure we'll be talking again
chris doherty from the center
for a new american security in
washington d.c chris we appreciate your
time and your insights tonight thank you
thank you
you